Es uno de los países más recónditos, perdidos
y desconocidos que existen.
¿Una prueba? Os hago 3 preguntas: ¿Alguna
vez has escuchado hablar de Uzbekistán? ¿Sabrías
situarlo exactamente en un mapa?
Y la tercera ¿Podrías decirme cuál es su
capital?
Si has respondido bien a las 3 preguntas,
enhorabuena eres todo un experto en geografía
internacional.
Si no es así, no te preocupes, es lo más
normal y hoy vas a tener la oportunidad de
descubrir muchas cosas, porque, amigos, hoy
en VisualPolitik, hablamos de Uzbekistán.
Puede que sea no sea muy popular pero, con
más de 30 millones de habitantes, Uzbekistán
es el país más poblado de Asia central.
Y es un país súper-joven.
En los dos sentidos, no solo porque 1 de cada
3 habitantes tiene menos de 14 años sino
también porque que el país formaba parte
de la Unión Soviética, así que como país
moderno, Uzbekistán apenas tiene 28 añitos.
Y amigos, es un país remoto.
(Uzbekistán está tan aislado del resto del
mundo que no es que no tenga salida al mar
sino que junto a Liechtenstein es el único
país de todo el planeta que está rodeado
por países que tampoco tienen salida al mar.
Y desde luego sus vecinos no es que sean miss
popularidad: Kirguistán, Tayikistán, Turkmenistán,
Kazajistán y Afganistán.)
[Bueno, este último sí es muy conocido,
aunque no para bien]
En fin, ya lo veis. Si queréis vivir en pleno
siglo XXI una aventura, propia de todo un
explorador, alejaros del mundo conocido y
sentiros como Ryszard Kapuscinski, David Livingstone
o incluso, ¿por qué no? Marco Polo, entonces
este puede ser un buen destino.
Pero amigos, evidentemente, esto no es un
anuncio de viajes, así que os hago una pregunta:
¿Por qué diantres pensáis que en VisualPolitik
hablamos de Uzbekistán?
¿Alguna idea?
¿Qué os parece si os digo que este país
está en plena encrucijada?
Fijaos, Uzbekistán, un país del tamaño
de California pero con solo el 1,5% del PIB
californiano, un país donde apenas 1 de cada
3 habitantes vive en las ciudades, tiene que
tomar una importante decisión.
lanzarse a un programa completo de reformas
que lo ponga, de una vez por todas rumbo a
convertirse en una economía del siglo XXI
o, por el contrario, volver a encerrarse y
desaparecer para el resto del mundo.
Y qué queréis que os diga, este tipo de
cosas, en VisualPolitik nos encantan.
En este vídeo vamos a ver qué está ocurriendo
en Uzbekistán, pero antes, antes tenemos
que conocer a un personaje: ¿Os suena el
nombre de Islam Karimov?
Atentos.
(MANO DURA, BOLSILLO LLENO)
Amigos, hay ocasiones donde todo cambia para
que en el fondo las cosas sigan prácticamente
igual… Y eso es precisamente lo que pasó
en Uzbekistán cuando en 1991 este país declaró
su independencia de la desmoronada Unión
Soviética.
En ese momento, este hombre que estáis viendo,
Islam Karimov era el Secretario General del
Partido Comunista en Uzbekistán y al mismo
tiempo el Presidente de la República Socialista
Soviética Uzbeka.
Y claro, si tenía todo el poder en sus manos,
¿para qué soltarlo? Esa la cuestión que
debió hacerse el propio Karimov que, por
supuesto, decidió no hacerlo.
///El día 1 de septiembre de 1991 cuando
aún no estaba del todo claro que la Unión
Soviética terminaría por desintegrarse,
Karimov vio clara la jugada y declaró la
independencia de Uzbekistán.
El 29 de diciembre de ese mismo año se celebraron
unas elecciones tan fraudulentas que, amigos,
hasta el mismísimo Nicolás Maduro parecería
Nelson Mandela.
Karimov se hizo con el 88% de los votos y
a partir de ahí… ¿sabéis qué? nunca
bajó el resultado. Karimov sabía cómo mantener
el porcentaje de votos.
Total, le bastaba con hacer una llamada a
la Junta Electoral y dictarles el resultado
de las elecciones, antes de que se celebrarán,
claro. Ya está, eso era más que suficiente///
El caso, amigos, es que durante sus 25 largos
años en el poder, Islam Karimov se convirtió
en el amo y señor de Uzbekistán. Uno de
los tiranos más despiadados del planeta.
Un tipo capaz de decir algo así públicamente,
atentos:
(“Estoy preparado para arrancar las cabezas
de 200 personas... con el fin de salvar la
paz y la calma en la República”. Islam
Karimov en Uzbek radio)
(Karimov supervisó abusos de derechos humanos
realmente terribles durante sus más de 25
años como presidente de Uzbekistán "Hugh
Williamson, de Human Rights Watch.)
Durante sus años en el poder, la censura
de los medios de comunicación fue una de
las más estrictas de todo el planeta;
las detenciones y condenas a periodistas y
activistas sociales y políticos fueron continuas;
la policía y los servicios secretos utilizaban
la tortura como parte del protocolo habitual.
El resultado es que, por supuesto, en Uzbekistán
nadie se atrevía a hablar mal del presidente.
Además Karimov utilizó la expropiación
como un mecanismo habitual para consolidar
su poder [Sí, lo siento, aquí Hugo Chávez
tampoco fue un gran innovador, más bien un
aprendiz ]
y preservó un montón de políticas económicas
que aprendió durante la etapa soviética:
políticas como controles de divisas, tasas
oficiales de cambio completamente artificiales,
un papel enorme del estado en la economía,
etcétera, etcétera.
Para colmo, a pesar de estar tan aislado,
se llevaba fatal con la mayoría de su vecinos.
(Todo esto es lo que explica que bajo su mandato
la mayoría de la población fuese pobre,
muy pobre, a pesar de que Uzbekistán es un
país muy rico en hidrocarburos y recursos
minerales. Por ejemplo las terceras mayores
reservas de oro de todo el planeta.
[Por cierto, no os podemos dar el porcentaje
de pobreza porque formalmente el gobierno
uzbeko determinó por ley que en el país
no existe la pobreza. Y si no existe pues…
no se mide]
Eso sí, para que os hagáis una idea pensad
que el salario medio es de 225 dólares mensuales
en los empleos formales. En los informales
es aún más bajo.)
Mientras tanto, como fácilmente podéis imaginar
la familia y el círculo de Karimov acumularon
una inmensa fortuna.
Las propias hijas de Karimov se han paseado
por los lugares más glamurosos del mundo,
han compartido vivencias con las grandes estrellas
de Hollywood, han sacado discos, líneas de
joyas, perfumes… todo lo que les hiciera
gracia.
Pero amigos, tal vez donde mejor podemos ver
lo inmensamente tirano, despótico, autócrata
que era el gobierno de Karimov es echando
un vistazo a lo que ocurría con el sector
del algodón, tradicionalmente la actividad
económica más importante del país.
Uzbekistán es uno de los mayores productores
de algodón del mundo.
El caso es que, ¿Podéis imaginar un país
donde cada año el líder esclaviza a un porcentaje
muy importante de la población para que trabajen
para él? [Y no, no seais mal pensados, en
esta ocasión no estamos hablando de los impuestos,
sino de trabajo forzoso]
Pues, eso es exactamente lo que ocurría en
Uzbekistán.
Así es, cada año, entre septiembre y noviembre,
para recoger la cosecha de algodón, el gobierno
movilizaba a entre 1 y 2 millones de personas
en condiciones prácticamente de esclavitud.
Para librarse de ir tenían que enviar a otra
persona o atenerse a las consecuencias.
La mayor parte eran trabajadores públicos,
como médicos y profesores, o trabajadores
de empresas que trabajaban para el gobierno.
Sí, habéis escuchado bien. De hecho un montón
de hospitales, por ejemplo, se quedaban prácticamente
sin médicos porque el gobierno les enviaba
a recoger algodón.
Vienes al trabajo todo preparado, vistiendo
ropa bonita, buenos zapatos, y el director
del policlínico corre y te dice: "Necesito
a 40 personas en el campo, el autobús está
afuera, apúrate, ¡apúrate!
El algodón es obligatorio para todos. El
gobierno da las órdenes y tu no puedes ir
en contra de esas órdenes ... Si me niego,
me despedirán…. Perderíamos el pan que
comemos”.
Y no solo eso, gran parte de estos trabajadores
forzados durante muchos años fueron niños,
que tenían que dejar de ir al colegio para
recoger algodón para el gobierno.
Y es que, amigos, el sistema era el siguiente.
Los agricultores recibían mano de obra gratis
y luego le vendían el algodón al gobierno
a un precio por los suelos. Luego el gobierno
era quien se lo vendía a las empresas textiles
o lo exportaba a un precio muchísimo mayor
del que había pagado a los agricultores para
producir ropa a lo largo y ancho del mundo.
De ahí que el algodón se convirtiera en
una de las mayores fuentes de ingresos del
gobierno.
En fin ya lo véis, Karimov no se andaba con
chiquitas.
//Tal vez otro ejemplo de lo despótico y
autoritario que era Karimov lo podemos encontrar
en cómo trató a su propia hija.
Veréis, Karimova era por así decirlo la
hija favorita, incluso se especulaba con que
sería su heredera. Vivía a todo trapo, rodeada
de lujos y celebridades y era muy popular
entre la jet-set mundial.
Por cierto, entre otras cosas fue embajadora
en España.
Pues bien, el caso es que Karimova le causó
un problema al gobierno porque había estado
cientos de millones de dólares a empresas
internacionales a cambio de falsas concesiones
en Uzbekistán. Y luego para colmo discutió
y en enfrentó públicamente con su madre
y con su hermano. Eso ya fue demasiado.
Un buen día, Karimov envió a la policía
secreta a casa de su hija con un operativo
propio de las películas de Hollywood. Vestidos
de negro asaltaron la casa de karimova lanzándose
con cuerdas desde helicópteros, la detuvieran
y la encerraron en la habitación de una mansión.
Karimova, una de las mujeres más ricas del
mundo, no volvió a ver a su padre y nadie
la ha vuelto a ver a ella. Ahora sabemos que
la han trasladado a una prisión uzbeka. El
juicio que la condenó se celebró en su propia
cocina.
Os lo hemos dicho, Karimov no se andaba con
chiquitas///.
¿Sorprendidos? Bueno, pues a pesar de todo
ello, ojo, Karimov fue un buen aliado de Occidente,
especialmente de los Estados Unidos.
Sí, lo habéis escuchado bien.
Pero… un momento! Stop! ¿Cómo pueden los
países occidentales ser aliados de semejante
tirano?
Bueno digamos que había dos motivos de peso.
Veréis, por un lado Uzbekistán es un país
mayoritariamente musulmán, pero el gobierno
de Karimov se oponía con todas sus fuerzas
al islamismo radical… y lo perseguía con
la misma mano dura con la que mantenía sometido
a su pueblo. Bueno incluso con más mano dura.
[Evidentemente no lo hacía por convicción
o por defender las libertades o la tolerancia
sino porque le suponía una clara amenaza
para poder]
Por otro lado, Uzbekistán tiene frontera
con Afganistán y eso es algo que a los Estados
Unidos, tras la invasión de Afganistán le
vino muy bien.
De hecho, el Pentágono instaló una base
aérea en el sur del país, eso sí, a cambio
de regar de dinero al régimen de Karimov.
Solo en 2002 el gobierno uzbeko recibió 500
millones de dólares.
[Cosas de la política internacional. En fin…]
Pero, amigos, en 2016 con la muerte de Karimov
todo esto llegó a su fin.
Y ahora la pregunta es, ¿ha comenzando realmente
nueva era? Atentos.
(CAMBIO O NO CAMBIO)
Prestad atención a esta noticia:
(Uzbekistán emerge del aislamiento con la
venta de 1.000 millones de dólares en bonos)
En febrero del 2019, el gobierno de Uzbekistán
hizo su primera emisión de bonos en el mercado
internacional emitiendo en Londres eurobonos
por valor de 1.000 millones de dólares.
Y, ¿Sabéis qué? Los inversores internacionales
se los quitaron de las manos. La demanda fue
8 veces mayor que la oferta.
La pregunta es, ¿Qué inversor en su sano
juicio le prestaría dinero a un gobierno
como este?
///Pues queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
el caso es que tras la muerte de Karimov,
subió a la presidencia su número 2, el Primer
Ministro, Shavkat Mirziyoyev, del que todo
el mundo esperaba que siguiera los pasos de
su predecesor. Al fin y al cabo era su Primer
Ministro.
Sin embargo, para sorpresa general, Mirziyoyev
anunció un montón de reformas para abrir
el país al mundo.
Por ejemplo, mejoró las relaciones con sus
vecinos, prohibió el trabajo forzoso en la
cosecha del algodón, purgó a los altos mandos
de los servicios de seguridad que habían
liderado la represión, liberó a un montón
de presos políticos y sacó a 18.000 personas
de una lista negra del gobierno que les impedía
viajar o poder trabajar.
Tan solo la mejora de las relaciones con sus
vecinos y la reapertura de los pasos fronterizos
ha hecho que el comercio de Uzbekistán con
el resto de países de Asia Central se haya
incrementado un 50% desde el año 2017. Es
decir, en apenas 2 años.)
Y, esperad un momento porque ahí no termina
todo. Con mucha diferencia, donde más cambios
se han producido ha sido en la política económica.
El nuevo gobierno ha eliminado los controles
de capitales y gran parte de los controles
de precios;
ha anunciado la privatización de la mayoría
de las empresas públicas;
ha reducido los aranceles y le ha dado vía
libre a las empresas uzbekas para que exporten
sin tener que pedirle permiso al gobierno
ni tener que pagarle.
También han anunciado impuestos más bajos
para los uzbekos y sobre todo para las empresas
que inviertan en el país.
[Vamos, todo lo contrario de lo que al final
ha terminado haciendo Mauricio Macri. Presidente,
que le tenga que dar lecciones el presidente
de Uzbekistán…]
Incluso, como los funcionarios del país han
sido tradicionalmente muy corruptos… el
Ministro de Hacienda, el señor Kuchkarov
ha decretado una moratoria de 3 años en todas
las inspecciones a las empresas mientras el
gobierno mejora sus procesos y reduce la burocracia.
Curioso.
El caso, amigos, es que son todos estos motivos
los que han hecho que los pronósticos sobre
el futuro del país hayan mejorado tanto que
el gobierno ahora puede emitir deuda en el
mercado de Londres sin que los inversores
salgan corriendo.
Ahora bien, ¿Quiere decir esto que Uzbekistán
se ha transformado por completo? Pues no,
para nada.
Uzbekistán, aunque mejor que con Karimov,
sigue siendo un país con un gobierno represor,
sigue existiendo la censura y todavía no
se vislumbran elecciones libres. Y por supuesto
el presidente Mirziyoyev tiene un control
enorme sobre todo lo que pasa en este país.
Digamos que el proceso acaba de comenzar…
si es que realmente ha comenzado.
Pero, amigo, eso solo lo podremos ver con
el tiempo. Y desde luego en VisualPolitik
estaremos muy atentos, porque no me digáis
que esta no es una historia es super interesante.
De hecho creo que este ha sido un vídeo 100%
VisualPolitik
Asi que ya sabéis si queréis seguir conociendo
historias que ocurren en el mundo, no os olvidéis
suscribiros al canal y si os ha resultado
interesante dadle like.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.